you've also during that stream got to
interact one of the greatest athletes of
all time burke pressure
what's your he's actually doing i don't
know if you're paying attention to this
but i guess he has a goal of running
2000 miles this year
yeah i've got a chance to talk to joe
rogan uh
yesterday about this which is uh
fascinating
i think he's a little bit doubtful of
albert's ability to be the ultra
performer that he so naturally is
yeah um what's your thoughts about bert
as a runner what's your advice to him
and what was your interaction like on as
part of this treadmill challenge with
him
i love bert because he's such a nice
person i mean
as a guy who's just accelerated in
popularity over the last few years like
he is like super kind so for folks who
are curious like
i met bert a couple years earlier and i
just
randomly asked him like hey i'm doing
this live stream thing we're doing it
for fight for the forgotten we're trying
to raise some funds for them
would you want to come on the live
stream for a bit and i thought maybe
he'd
come off like five or ten minutes and i
thought that would be amazing if he did
that he ended up coming on for like over
an hour he said he went past his slot
sat in the next slot and just started
talking with some of the other guests
it's he's just uh bert is definitely
like i feel like he's as
unchanged from like his popularity as
one can get away with
and it's just like his his lifestyle i
think is very
un unpredictable in the sense that like
if he wants to run like x time for a
specific race
that's going to pull away from his
lifestyle so much to focus on that
luckily for him he's actually a great
athlete like you it's it's under that
layer of
fat yeah so people who are not familiar
burke crashes a comedian who takes off
his shirt often
has he's a uh elegant
layer of fat around him he's also a
party animal
so he's a weird balance of like healthy
and unhealthy
yeah so he drinks a lot during
i think there's some debate about that
but certainly after
his uh his performances but at the same
time he's into
kind of the running thing and he does
quite a bit of treadmill running i think
so and like i said has this challenge of
running 2000 miles this year
so it's fascinating to have somebody who
so fully embraces
life and the full joys of life as
represented by the
huge amounts of drinking and partying
and just being a wild man
but also at the same time like being at
least curious about this
challenging yourself in the physical
realm it's kind of fascinating
it reminds me of um one of my favorite
comedians like eddie izzard
who has been doing those challenges
basically off the couch just running
a marathon a day kind of thing it's
fascinating
to see the purity of those challenges
when like exercise hasn't necessarily
been
deeply great ingrained in your life and
you kind of just embrace the challenge
anyway
and take it on and that's another way of
looking at it because we've been talking
about running as a
a performance like optimization thing
where
training is such a huge part of this
process like race day is just the cherry
on top
but there's for some people where the
race is the cake
yeah it's like they just take it on as a
pure challenge as the
as the as the thing you haven't really
trained for as a thing you haven't
you don't understand the intricacies of
but you take it on anyway and that
that reveals something about the human
spirit as well yeah and there's
definitely like a
switch that flips when you in your mind
decide i'm gonna do this yeah where then
all of a sudden it goes from like
you stop thinking about oh that's not
possible it's like well i'm just gonna
do it and i think
burt highlights that perfectly in a lot
of cases where like
he's he's maybe not even thinking it
through enough to get to the point where
it's like he gets the point where he
thinks this is not possible
where most people would look at it and
think huh i don't know if i can actually
physically
accomplish that task burt's just like oh
yeah i'm going to do it
and my my thought with bert was the 2000
mile thing is
where are we going to find him at the
end of the year with like 36 hours to go
on a hundred miles and he's getting
right
that's right that's what's going to
happen
and it's going to be hilarious
you